UNTIL AFTER THE GEORGIA
ELECTION.
THAT’S A KEY POINT.
RICH, THANKS SO MUCH.
LET’S TAKE A LIVE LOOK AT
CAPITOL HILL WHERE A NEW
CONGRESS IS GOING TO BE SWORN
IN FOR A RARE SUNDAY SESSION.
THAT’S TOMORROW AS LAWMAKERS
CALL FOR EVEN MORE STIMULUS.
MY NEXT GUEST IS A NEWLY
ELECTED CONGRESSMAN, WILL HE
SUPPORT IT?
AUGUST P LCHLTL --
PFLUGER.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
ARE YOU FOR THAT $2,000 CHECK?
>> AS HAS BEEN MENTIONED
SOMETHING TAKEN UP IN THIS
CURRENT CONGRESS, ANY NEW
PROVISIONS FOR BILLS I WANT TO
SEE THE DETAILS AND UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT IS THAT’S GOING TO BE
HELPING THE WORKING CLASS
AMERICANS OF NO-FAULT OF THEIR
OPEN.
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN SHUT
DOWN AND THEY’RE ON LOCKDOWN.
I’M PROUD OF THE JUDGES AND
THOSE IN MY DISTRICT TO KEEP
AMERICANS SAFE AND TO FIGHT TO
KEEP OUR BUSINESSES OPEN.
THE LARGER QUESTION,  WE NEED
TO GET BACK TO WORK AND THE
ECONOMY TO GET BACK.
DAVID: WE SURE DO, THE POINT IS
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
SUFFERING TERRIBLY.
ACCORDING TO ONE POLL ABOUT 80%
OF AMERICANS FAVOR THAT $2,000
OVER THE $600 CHECK AND THERE’S
A FURTHER QUESTION ABOUT HOW
MCCONNELL’S MANEUVERINGS TO NOT
VOTE ON IT BEFORE THE GEORGIA
ELECTION WILL AFFECT THE
GEORGIA ELECTION, ARE YOU
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, WE’RE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE GEORGIA ELECTION FOR SURE,
YES, YOU’RE RIGHT.
THERE ARE MANY AMERICANS
SUFFERING THAT NEED HELP THAT
TARGETED HELP, AND THEY NEED
PROGRAMS LIKE PPP TO HELP THEIR
BUSINESSES GET BACK TO NORMAL.
SO, YEAH, WE’LL HAVE TO SEE HOW
IT UNFOLDS AND OBVIOUSLY, HAS
BEEN STATED ON YOUR SHOW
ALREADY, THE TURNOUT IN GEORGIA
IS GOING TO BE KEY.
WE NEED FOLKS TO GET OUT AND TO
VOTE FOR MR. PURDUE,
MS. LOEFFLER TO KEEP THE SENATE
AND KEEP IT RED.
DAVID: AS I MENTIONED, YOU ARE
A PROUD VETERAN OF THE WARS IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
YOU FLEW--
YOU WERE ACTIVE FOR 20 YEARS IN
THE AIR FORCE.
YOU’RE ACTUALLY, I BELIEVE,
STILL A LT. COLONEL IN THE
RESERVES, AM I RIGHT ON THAT?
>> I’M A COLONEL IN THE
RESERVES, THAT’S RIGHT.
DAVID: AND YOU WERE ON
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S SECURITY
COUNSEL.
SECURITY COUNCIL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS THE
GREATEST THREAT?
>> NO DOUBT IT’S CHINA AND THE
PRESIDENT RIGHTFULLY THREE
YEARS AGO PIVOTED OUR FOCUS TO
CHINA, THIS EXISTENTIAL THREAT,
THIS GREAT POWER
ADMINISTRATION, I’M WORRIED
ABOUT THE INCOMING
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR LACK
OF FOCUS AND WE’LL BE WATCHING
CLOSELY THEIR CABINET PICKS TO
MAKE SURE THEY’RE FOCUSED ON
CHINA BECAUSE IT’S CERTAINLY A
FOCUS OF MINE AND MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE MILITARY AND THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN IN THE NATIONAL
SECURITY BUSINESS AND WE’RE
GOING TO BE WATCHING CLOSELY TO
SEE WHAT THEIR ACTIONS ARE.
DAVID: AND I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
YOU WERE QUITE CONCERNED THAT A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE, WHO HAD NO
EXPERIENCE TO BE ON THAT
COMMITTEE WHEN HE WAS
APPOINTED, BY THE WAY, WAS
COMPROMISED BY A CHINESE
COMMUNIST SPY?
>> WELL, THAT’S JUST ABSOLUTELY
DISGUSTING TO THINK THAT
SOMEBODY COULD BE COMPROMISED
AND BE ON THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE.
HUNTER BIDEN’S DEALINGS WITH
CHINESE BUSINESSES.
ALL OF THESE THINGS LEAD US TO
BELIEVE THERE IS A LACK OF
FOCUS, THAT THERE IS A REAL
LACK OF CONCERN ABOUT CHINA AS
A THREAT, WHICH IS WHY THIS
INCOMING CLASS OF 43 FRESHMEN,
THE MOST DIVERSE CLASS IN THE
HISTORY WITH MORE WOMEN, MORE
MINORITIES, MORE VETERANS, VERY
PROUD OF THIS CLASS.
THEY HAVE THE FOCUS.
WE’RE GOING TO BE FIGHTING FOR
OUR DISTRICTS, FIGHTING FOR OUR
COUNTRY, FOR OUR SECURITY.
DAVID: VERY QUICKLY.
ARE YOU GOING TO TRY TO GET ON
THAT HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE?
YOU CERTAINLY HAVE THE
CREDENTIALS FOR IT, UNLIKE
MR. SWALWELL.
WILL YOU GET ON IT AND DO YOU
RECOMMEND THAT HE RESIGN FROM
THAT COMMITTEE?
>> WELL, FOR SURE I RECOMMEND
THAT HE RESIGN AND WE’LL SEE
WHETHER OR NOT I GET ON THAT
COMMITTEE.
BUT MY FOCUS WILL BE FIRST AND
FOREMOST, MY DISTRICT FOR THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ITEMS, THAT
WE REPRESENT, WHICH INCLUDE OIL
AND GAS, AGRICULTURE AND THE
MILITARY SO ANYBODY THAT
DOESN’T HAVE THOSE AGENDA ITEMS
THAT’S ON THAT COMMITTEE,
INCLUDING MR. SWALWELL, NEEDS
TO RESIGN FOR SOMETHING THAT IS
CLEARLY A COMPROMISE AND A
CONTRADICTION OF HOLDING OUR
CONSTITUTION.
DAVID: CONGRESSMAN-ELECT AUGUST